ci sono un ingegnere strutturista un
fisico teorico e un urbanista e non è
una barzelletta e l'agosto 2016 e
decidono di sedersi attorno a un tavolo
per vincere un progetto partecipano al
bando periferie per portare alla città
di messina 18 milioni di euro da
investire riqualificazione urbana quando
si parla di periferie
il pensiero va ai paradossi della città
contemporanea a queste enormi distanze
tra ricchezza e povertà ai centri urbani
sempre più fast green smart che
convivono con enormi aree marginali e
degradate tutte con molteplici anime e
tipologie edilizie diverse parafrasando
tolstoj tutte le città felici sono
simili tra loro
ogni periferia infelice è infelice a
modo proprio e queste storie queste
genesi tutte diverse vanno raccontate
rasa al suolo due volte nel secolo
scorso una volta dal terremoto del 1908
e poi nel 1943 dai bombardamenti alleati
messina è tra le città europee con il
più grande disagio abitativo
questa emergenza continua sul tema della
casa ne ha fatto un air show e di
scambio sottendendo un doppio ricatto
quello politico clientelare e quello del
baraccato in attesa pretesa della casa
consumandosi nella retorica delle
promesse e delle attese
questa città si è ripiegata su se stessa
proprio per questo motivo per provare a
dare risposte non si poteva non cogliere
l'occasione offerta dal bando
e allora attorno a quel tavolo si
ragiona di opportunità
e in effetti questo bando può essere
interpretato in maniera creativa può
forse con qualche forzatura lasciare lo
spazio per mettere insieme azioni
materiali leca legate alla
riqualificazione degli spazi urbani
quindi alla fisicità della città e
azioni immateriali attraverso iniziative
sociali
inoltre forse è la volta buona perché in
questa città non si ragioni secondo le
opportunità aprendo un cassetto e
tirando fuori progetti già esistenti e
trasformando la proposta semplicemente
in un elenco è invece è possibile
organizzare un programma di lavoro
un piano che abbia una visione
strategica di sviluppo e poi forse si
può usare per che bella risposta alla
manifestazione di interesse con la quale
bisognava selezionare i partner attivi
sul territorio e co finanziatori del
progetto emerge un dato forse
sorprendente nella città di messina il
terzo settore è attivo ed è innovativo
più dell'imprenditoria privata
dovendo decidere su quale area della
città mandare avanti l'idea si rileva
che la presenza più intensa più
effervescente più forte di questi attori
sociali e nella zona sud
cena guarda caso lì dove è anche più
grande la povertà è più grande di
degrado e ci sono le baraccopoli più
problematiche come a dire che laddove si
muore sette anni prima della media
cittadina e si muore quattro volte di
più nei primi giorni dopo la nascita
proprio lì si sviluppano gli anticorpi
più potenti e allora come organizzare
questa idea come portare avanti un
progetto che possa trovare le risposte e
possa fare un ragionamento sul tema
della casa
proprio quel tema che ha messo in
ginocchio la città non può quindi essere
una risposta banale e indirizzata
soltanto a quello bisogna guardare la
città e bisogna ricordarsi che quando
entriamo in una casa quando la vediamo
quando scriviamo il nostro nome su una
targhetta la abitiamo
ma quando ci spostiamo in un'altra città
e ancora mettiamo il nostro nome sul
campanello non è detto che quello sia
abitare un luogo chiudere la porta non
significa sentirsi a casa perché manca
tutto lo spazio delle relazioni quindi
in quest'area bisognava assolutamente
trovare risposte al problema
dell'abitare
ma bisognava interpretare questo tema in
maniera più ampia e più aperta nei
confronti della struttura urbana in
effetti in quest'area ci sono delle
potenzialità intanto c'è un
tracciato della ferrovia dismessa che
può diventare un elemento forte in
funzione di una mobilità dolce una
mobilità sostenibile
inoltre sullo stesso tracciato esiste un
ponte il ponte di camaro che già memoria
collettiva e che una presenza forte
all'interno della città quindi da una
parte questa vitalità nel sociale
dall'altra le potenzialità dello
dell'area rappresentano degli elementi
importanti su cui costruire il progetto
l'ingegnere con lo spirito pragmatico
che lo contraddistingue
crede che i passaggi burocratici sulla
casa i tempi infiniti debbono essere
ridotti e quindi perché non trovare un
modo con il quale poter dare la somma
utile ai baraccati per acquistare un
alloggio scegliendolo sul mercato il
fisico completamente calato in grado
anche di coinvolgere i suoi compagni di
lavoro sul tema della del paradigma
dello sviluppo umano sulle capacità
azioni di marcia sen
sulla possibilità di dare un ventaglio
di scelta di scelte alle persone per
potersi autodeterminare e allora perché
non chiamare capitale di capacitazione
quell'intuizione dell'ingegnere che
aveva detto diamo direttamente i soldi
alle persone affinché possano scegliere
l'alloggio dove vogliono
l'urbanista dice che bisogna tenere
tutte insieme e al di là insieme in
maniera sistemica alle azioni sociali
ai passaggi legati a questa libertà di
autodeterminazione
bisogna dare un disegno a questo
progetto una struttura che consenta alla
città la parte sud della città di tenere
insieme tutto di tenere insieme la
faccia amare i percorsi ciclopedonali e
il recupero della parte collinare che ha
anche lì degli elementi significativi
come dei forti è un ex stazione ed ecco
il progetto capaciti il titolo evoca le
capabilities di marcia sen
quindi questa idea di libertà potenziata
l'asse quello della mobilità sostenibile
attraverso il recupero della ferrovia il
ponte che abbiamo visto poco fa
diventano un sistema integrato integrato
e diventano anche la struttura su cui
agganciare le altre azioni legate agli
assi l'asse dell'abitare che prevede
delle iniziative con particolare
profondità soprattutto nel polo di fondo
saccà e negli altri poli si sviluppano
azioni legate al lavoro al microcredito
al sostegno dell'imprenditorialità
giovanile e poi ancora azioni diffuse
sul territorio quindi quelle che
potremmo definire le azioni immateriali
del progetto che però qui lo si vede
sono anche localizzabili nel territorio
quindi è bello vedere come anche ciò che
generalmente non riusciamo a di fila di
segnare possa trovare una collocazione
all'interno della forma urbana e azioni
legate alla socialità ma anche alla
conoscenza come esperienze cognitive e
soprattutto rivolta ai bambini
ritorniamo al tema della casa quindi
abbiamo dei baraccati che devono uscire
e devono trovare questa possibilità lo
possono fare attraverso 33 punti tre
linee la prima è quella dell'accesso ad
un'abitazione nel condominio prototipo
di fondo saccà
la seconda è che il comune vada sul
mercato a cui si gli alloggi e l'idea ai
legittimi assegnatari e il terzo il più
interessante perché proprio la
rivoluzione è avvenuta con capacità e il
capitale di capacitazione ricordiamoci
quell'intuizione dell'ingegnere con il
titolo dato dal fisico
cos'è questo capitale di capacitazione
sembra l'uovo di colombo
come è stato possibile non pensarci
prima
perché si è consentito il consumo di
suolo e o si è perso tanto tempo nei
passaggi burocratici down e da un ente
all'altro in un periodo in cui i vani
vuoti in tutte le città sono
un'opportunità anche per riattivare il
mercato
e allora il capitale di capacitazione è
una una somma che viene erogata
attraverso le possibilità date dal bando
per far sì che le famiglie possano
scegliere un appartamento e possano
anche auto recuperarlo con il proprio
lavoro anche quello sostenuto con delle
somme apposite qual è il rischio di
questo ragionamento il progetto capaciti
è un sistema molto complesso con
equilibri particolari
in cui si è cercato di tenere insieme la
grande scala urbana e la scala di
dettaglio la scala dell'alloggio
siamo in una città in cui alla fine il
tema della casa e quello che fagocita
tutto ma in questo caso non deve
accadere perché significherebbe
banalizzare l'esperienza e ricondurla
soltanto all'acquisto gli alloggi non
era questa l'intenzione cosa succede nel
2017 nel gennaio 2017
il bando periferie da il risultato dei
vincitori e messina è tra i primi 20 e
accede a questo finanziamento unico caso
da napoli in giù e soprattutto accede
nella prima tranche dei finanziamenti
quindi un successo clamoroso e una
grande passaggio un passaggio epocale
perché è un programma con una visione
strategica che viene finanziato questo
programma è ancora in corso di
attuazione
gli attori sociali ne sono ancora
protagonisti là dove c'era la
baraccopoli
adesso c'è un
un piccolo parco con delle esperienze da
fare sul tema dell'efficientamento
energetico del condominio prototipale
c'è uno spazio socio ricreativo sociale
educativo è molto amato molto
frequentato ma soprattutto 163 persone
ad oggi hanno acquistato un alloggio lo
hanno scelto e lo hanno modificato
seguendo i loro sogni capacity ha
dimostrato che c'è un mondo possibile a
patto che sia la città a diventare casa
e che la casa sia uno strumento di
libertà e di cittadinanza
io ho scelto di comprare la casa acqua
nei pressi appunto perché stanno
nascendo il centro sociale dove io ho
intenzione di far usufruire i miei figli
per farvi vedere la rinascita di questo
di questo quartiere promesse io li ho
avuto fatte tante
perché io da 70 anni e vivo quando avevo
due anni quello di quando girato questa
casa due anni che forse qua tutte le
abitano vicini mary cuore vengono di
vero alla vera allora per tanti motivi
perché la casa è accogliente c'è un
percettivo fuori un bel pezzo
sono molto soddisfatto di questo
progetto dopo tantissimi anni 55 anni
che abita in questa casa a 74 anni
finalmente posso dire di avere una casa
con me la desidera voglio e bellina è
piccola ma è un amore e addirittura
quando non avevo la chiave andavo alla
villa gente mi guardava il balcone
perché non mi sembrava vero mi sembra
una cosa troppo bella per essere vera
questa è la villa dante e quest'oggi
vita a dire il mio angolo di paradiso
perché la mattina appena mi sveglio la
prima cosa che faccio
guarda gli alberi tutto questo verde che
mi dà tanta serenità vintage ariani
[Applauso]